ghostbusters afterlife has been a huge
success
columbia pictures
are already in negotiations to bring
back the sequel
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
ghostbusters afterlife took 44 million
dollars in its opening weekend now
post covid that's an amazing figure it
really really makes up for the
ghostbusters with boobs and
it's just phenomenal jason reitman did
an amazing job a genuinely amazing job i
giggled like a child at at least five
different places while watching this
film
and um it generally gave me goosebumps
there will be no spoilers in this video
except for one little one which i'm
going to talk about a little bit later
but i'll warn you when it's coming just
in case you haven't seen it already if
you haven't seen it i would just say why
the hell not
it is genuinely a worthy successor to
the original ghostbusters and it is
phenomenal now i have a couple of
sources already from having this channel
somebody i know is reasonably close to
colombia has told me that
negotiations for the sequel have already
begun columbia pictures are ecstatic
with the res with the response this
film's been getting and the critics
response has been a little bit mixed but
the audience response has been
phenomenal because it's a phenomenal
movie the rotten tomatoes rating is
through the roof imdb the same now
what would the sequel be about and has
jason reitman already been talking about
it well yes he has
he has already said ghostbusters 2 with
vigo is canon now there are actual
little easter eggs and things from the
ghostbusters 2 movie in this film
the biggest problem though is that
egon's daughter should have actually
been born already and when ghostbusters
2 came out and obviously she's nowhere
in the film so that's a little bit of a
problem on canon but you know
we just ignore that there are things
though like ray's a cult shop where we
see him at the in the halfway through
the movie oh sorry that's a little bit
of a spoiler sorry but he is in the
advert so it's not really that is
obviously from ghostbusters too that's
where he is at the start of ghostbusters
2. there are a couple of other little
bits as well throughout the film
jason rightman's already been talking
about that so he wants viggo maybe to
make return or very least he has said
ghostbusters afterlife 2
will have elements linking it to the
second ghostbusters film but i actually
think they've already teased us a few
little other bits of information there
is one scene towards the end of the
movie this is a bit of a spoiler so i'm
sorry that does stand out a little bit
winston zedemore
who apparently in the film has actually
since leaving ghostbusters has done very
well for himself and made himself quite
a lot of money taps um ecto-1 on the
bonnet and sort of says you're coming
home with me i'm gonna i'm gonna take
you home and look after you so i think
i think that is quite a big hint that
that seems sorry does just stand out a
little bit in the movie at the time i
was sort of like that's a bit weird um
but i'm thinking that's basically going
to be setting up for the sequel i can
actually see that winston is going to
perhaps
take on the mantle of training the next
generation of ghostbusters but for some
reason they need his help and that he
actually fixes up ecto-1 as i say
perhaps trains this new group of
youngsters that are going to become the
new ghostbusters i i think that is the
way we're going to go here but will we
see ray and will we see peter venkman
return
i actually genuinely think
um dan aykroyd would want to return for
this movie i think he loves the
ghostbusters franchise and it's the sort
of thing he'd be well up for doing um he
talked a lot about this film beforehand
he actually did make a little cameo in
the uh terrible ghostbusters that we
don't want to talk about bill murray on
the other hand is a bit of an enigma
wrapped in a mystery
it's there's actually a story that goes
even for the original ghostbusters they
weren't sure he was going to turn up
he said he was going to do the role he
he promised dan aykroyd that he was
going to turn up but they weren't really
sure he literally turned up on the first
day of filming they were they were just
relieved he has got a bit of a
reputation for not always
turning up he was even resistant to
doing this movie but i think the way
jason reitman did it convinced him that
this was actually a part worth doing and
his cameo towards the end of the movie
again i'm not going to say anyone that
is
stunning i think we're definitely going
to see winston and i think he's going to
have a big part in perhaps training or
getting the new ghostbusters ready maybe
he funds them maybe he he does whatever
else um i think we're going to see rey
come back because he's obviously
integral to a part and i think um dak
would be more than willing
um i don't think we'll see bill murray
but
there's a little thing on that
ghostbusters two if you remember
really centered around sigourney weaver
now sigourney weaver was very much
absent from ghostbusters afterlife could
we see a return for dana barrett and
more importantly
oscar now obviously oscar was a big part
of the movie because that's who vigo
were trying to um take over his body and
that's was going to be used as a conduit
for vigo returning to earth baby oscar
was a big part of ghostbusters 2.
it would only make sense to me that he
would return for afterlife 2.
with his return
could dane return now if dana returns an
oscar that really would leave an easy
opening for peter venkman to return
we don't really know what happened at
the end of ghostbusters 2 but it looked
like that the relationship with dana was
going to blossom again and that he was
going to be maybe a stepdad to oscar we
don't know obviously what happened in
that relationship but maybe it did
continue and that if oscar was at risk
again
that maybe peter venkman would step up
now that's a storyline that i could see
working
and it's a storyline that i can actually
see bill murray being interested in
enough to do
and obviously with afterlife doing so
well they're going to be in the position
to be able to throw a crapload of money
at bill murray ghostbusters afterlife
and the sequel seems to be not greenlit
yet but the negotiations are happening
colombia are very very happy jason
reitman already has an idea for a
storyline and i think the fact of this
being greenlit is only weeks away thanks
very much for watching if you are new to
the channel please like subscribe hit
that bell notification blah blah you can
now join the channel and give me a small
bit of money every week that um you know
keep my wife happy because you know my
stupid little hobby and if it makes
money she can't moan at me quite as much
but also it really helps going to help
me go to that next level because you
know i really want to grow this channel
and i really want to um you know get new
microphones and things so if you could
join the channel that would be amazing
also you will get the videos 24 hours
before anybody else and a couple other
little perks thank you so much for
watching and i will see you next time